hey guys you were watching GameSpot news
it is Tuesday my name is Jeff I'm Dan
and that is probably all the information
you need for now let's see you
but sup let's talk about getting you
some free stuff what we tell you ps4 and
Xbox one players a bunch of things you
can get free all the time so today let's
talk about the pc players gog commerce
kicked off its massive winter sale today
if you really don't want to spend any
money at all you can pick up Grim
Fandango remastered for free right now
for the next 35 ish hours depending on
when you're watching this head to good
ol Gamescom starting with your good old
games account or sign up for a free one
and just click the link on the front
page to redeem the game there's also a
ton about the deals on really great
games including 60% off The Witcher 3
25% off held late and 20% off what
remains of Edith Finch as well as like
900 other games
so chances are you'll find a deal on
something you've had your eye on it
looks like heaps to you guys are picking
up Nintendo switches this year why
wouldn't you with all the great games
that came out in fact 10 million units
of now console's Nintendo revealed the
figure today which is derived from the
publishers internal sales data through
the system's first 9 months that would
suggest that the data includes sales
from early December although Nintendo
didn't provide an exact cutoff date
Nintendo's previous tally was announced
back in September when the company
revealed they sold seven point six three
million units by the end of the month
currently the publisher expects to sell
fourteen million units during the
current fiscal year which puts the
switch on pace to top the lifetime sales
of the Wii U in just eight years time
finally the sequel to level 5 JRPG
mikuni has been delayed ninokuni 2 was
previously scheduled to be released on
January 19th on ps4 and PC that has been
pushed back to March 23rd according to a
press release the two months delay is to
ensure the games developer level 5 can
meet the studio's standards level 5
president Akihiro Hino said with
innovation and new ideas comes the need
to ensure everything works together in a
fun and cohesive way this means we'll
need a bit more time to make sure the
entire ninokuni to experience meets our
highest quality standards this is the
second time ninokuni has been delayed
from its original release date of
November 10 that is everything we've got
for you today do this now you can t
write down in that comment section and
we will be back the same time tomorrow
I hope to see that
you